alors on va faire une interview première
fois ah ouais t'as ton premier souvenir
par exemple c'était comment je me suis
retrouvé à avoir un caniche au lieu d'un
mouton
comment mahut comme ça et vous avez
c'est au marché qui était dans mon
village à mes angoisses et j'étais tombé
mais complètement amoureuse d'un petit
mouton tout blanc mignon au jeu devait
avoir quoi quatre ans et je dis je veux
le mouton je veux le mouton acheter la
même époque mais millions et ma mère me
dit écoute on va rentrer à la maison et
on reviendra tout allant le chercher
parce que tu vois je suis chargé tout ça
et je fais bon ben d'accord
sachant très bien n que le marché sont à
la une heure à 1,2 me ramène à nouveau
le mouton tu vois une partie membres là
je n'ai pas bougé je me suis jetée par
terre ça et ses séries mais il a fallu
aller chercher mes grands parents et mon
grand père a dit attends vient à la
maison je te promets que je vais être
amené fait pas un bon temps mais quelque
chose qui reformule est allé d'une
chercher un caniche nain très belle
histoire dont premier baiser dans la
cage d'ascenseur
parce que tu dis pas tu as dit que en
fait le coup de la langue tu l'avais vu
dans union parce que chez toi quand tu
étais petit il y avait des revues comme
ça qu'ils quittent rennais avait union
et puis avait des revues qui voulaient
dessus elle aussi teinté vraiment gentil
couple allanche président union si tu
savais ce que j'ai dit dans l'union et
dans d autres revue business events
avait six mois
j'attends beaucoup de la lente et voient
les choses par tout ça
car oui il y avait de tout acte ou du
moins dans cette vidéo c'était assez je
dis ça faisait des compositions
absolument c'était des pages pleines et
en tombe au père à l'époque tu as vu en
train de lire en cachette ces revues
mais qu'il a remarqué que les iset parce
que je l'avais parmi tout à fait à
l'aventuré
c'est à dire en fait un choix besoin de
te cacher pour les we can emmerder ainsi
mon talent mais moi je dis oui je sais
je sais y'a pas de problème est en fait
lui avait pas de problème c'est beaucoup
moins drôle c'est permis non non c'est
pas ça que 4 seulement passa toute façon
je ne faisais avant dans une ville
s'était permis moi j'ai jamais eu le
sentiment que c'était interdit
non c'était pas ça c'était que c'était
comme une intrusion dans mon intimité
oui et re sic et d'avoir effectué en
même temps de ne pas du tout pas du tout
c'était tout à fait qu'ils se balader à
poil à la maison mais tout le monde se
balader à poil et même d'un caniche
même le caniche ta première expérience
sexuelle
c'est à dire la chose c'est à dire la
chose sexuelle
ça veut dire quoi tu veux savoir quoi la
première fois au but et fait sauter ses
principes non mais si tu n'as absolument
pas précis parce que dans à la première
fois suite à ses soucis je peux te dire
mardi matin 11 heures la première fois
dans un pays bas mardi matin 11 heures
ça répond à ta question n'est pas
critique taquet à présent et demi en
fait non je vais te dire ma question je
veux savoir si c'était ton ton parolier
du bal où ton compositeur alain ski
parce que je sais pas très bien mais
coutumes leur demandera de revient tv
c'était en belgique c'était une émission
de sa plage quand génération 80 nouvelle
traque
or vous savez vous m'y attends
maintenant ça va tu es plus le trac
si j'avais encore le trac on fait que ce
soit j'ai pas le trac
donc au lieu dit le premier bide
finalement je sais pas c'est peut-être
quand j'ai signé mon premier contrat de
disque dur était de réfléchir à deux
fois j'en sais rien mais en tout cas je
sais que mon corps me bodied c'était
quand j'étais en simple dont combien
noël je m'en souviens pas particulier
mais je me souviens bien de la
préparation autour de noël à un voyage
au portugal parce que vous en aller avec
mon grand père coupait un sapin à la
tombée de la nuit
il disait qu ibra connaît enfin je suis
même passé au sofitel dans un terrain
derrière chelsea mais cette partie ci
fait complètement l aventure c'était
bien et puis on aller cueillir la mousse
au pied des arbres en tapisser la crèche
et c'était bien